[Musik]
es ist viertel nach acht meine damen und
herren herzlich willkommen zu viertel
nach acht dem tag der schlacht ich freue
mich dass sie dabei sind an den
bildschirmen ich freue mich über tolle
gäste hier im studio johannes als spd
bundestagsabgeordneter und offizier
miriam rehbein unternehmerin und
fachärztin mein sehr geschätzter bild
kollege sebastian geisler und der fdp
fraktionsvorsitzende martin haag fdp
fraktionsvorsitzender in bayern muss ich
dazu sagen mein name ist jan schäfer
unser konzept heute abend ganz einfach
fünf köpfe hier im studio fünf
verschiedene themen fünf hoffentlich
auch sehr kontroverse meinungen und ich
habe die ehre direkt starten zu dürfen
dürfen mit einem thema das mich heute
sehr beschäftigt hat die person des
tages für mich heute karl lauterbach der
gesundheitsminister der hat mir nicht
ganz nebenbei seine corona strategie
gewechselt man muss sagen nicht nur
seine krone strategie sondern eigentlich
die korona strategie der vergangenen
zwei jahre bisher wurden maßnahmen
lockdown maßnahmen alle einschränkungen
eigentlich damit begründet eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
verhindern zu wollen also ein kollaps
beispielsweise von klinik aber heute hat
aber etwas ganz anderes gesagt er hat
gesagt es darf keine lockerungen der
aktuellen corona maßnahmen geben weil es
weiterhin 100 bis 150 tote am tag gibt
um das ganz klar zu sagen jeder tote in
der pandemie aber auch jeder andere tote
ist ein toter zu viel das ist ganz klar
aber natürlich birgt das leben risiken
und auch in dieser pandemie geht es um
eine risikoabwägung denn es gibt
natürlich auch menschen die an grippe
sterben menschen die ein autounfall
erleiden
und dann dabei zu tode kommen also was
karl lauterbach hier überhaupt nicht
gedacht hat ist dass es beispielsweise
auch durch die harten corona maßnahmen
viele viele millionen menschen gibt die
leiden die gesundheitlich leiden ist
gefährlich was karl lauterbach gemacht
hat denn er hat unterschieden er hat
quasi gesagt ein menschenleben das von
corona gerettet werden kann ist
wichtiger als ein menschenleben dass
beispielsweise durch ein krebsleiden
davor einem krebsleiden
gerettet werden kann das ist ein
falscher weg karl lauterbach das geht
nicht der staat muss menschenwürde
garantieren er kann nicht dass
menschenleben garantieren
ja da muss ich jetzt auch mal direkt
einhalten wenn ich darf ich finde wir
verkennen bei dieser ganzen kroner
politik vor allen dingen das ja diese
überlastung der krankenhäuser nicht
corona geschuldet ist sondern
tatsächlich zum einen auch den mangel an
personal verschuldet ist ich kann ich
aus eigener erfahrung gerade sprechen
bin vor fünf mutter geworden und war
dann selbst mal patient im krankenhaus
als ärztin habe das mal live erleben
können und dürfte feststellen dass es
auf der gesamten station zwei
krankenschwestern gab was dazu führte
dass wenn man klingelt weil man noch
betrübt da lag niemand gekommen ist weil
keiner kommen konnte und die sind nicht
etwa nicht gekommen weil das ganze
personal krank ist sondern erstens wer
will diesen job noch machen das ist
tatsächlich ein problem weil die arbeit
im krankenhaus ist hart und wird
schlecht bezahlt das ist de facto so und
damit diesen quarantänemaßnahmen wir
natürlich unglaublich viel rein
theoretisch gesundes personal in
quarantäne haben was nicht zur arbeit
kommen darf und wir sozusagen da
wirklich sozusagen der der katzenschwanz
abschneiden also es wird wirklich
schwierig überhaupt noch wirtschaftlich
zu funktionieren als krankenhaus und mit
dieser kursänderung mehr tote verhindern
ich finde es nur noch absurd also ich
finde es als erster unternehmerin die
politik nur noch absurd und das
vertrauen in diese politik geht gegen
null
absurde politiker als sebastian geisler
also was ich mich dann gefragt habe ist
ja ok karl lauterbach da denkt man der
setzt jetzt auf gesundheitsschutz weil
er halt gesundheitspolitiker ist aber er
sitzt ja offensichtlich ausschließlich
im grunde auf diesen corona schutz und
ist nicht in der lage eine abwägung
nicht mal innerhalb sozusagen der
gesundheitsfrage vorzunehmen wenn es ihm
offensichtlich nach wie vor egal ist was
ist zb bei der zahl der suizide
psychische erkrankungen und was da los
ist das muss man doch mal zur kenntnis
nehmen warum ist er nach wie vor
offensichtlich nicht in der lage das in
einer in seine maßnahmen finden hier mit
einzubeziehen das verstehe ich nicht ich
habe mittlerweile den eindruck wolfgang
kubicki hat ja nun vielleicht sich auch
unglücklich eingelassen die man sagt in
seinem lokal mit bande karl lauterbach
einen spacken na gut hat er gesagt hat
ich würde eher den eindruck vielleicht
ist karl lauterbach ein anderer
entschuldigung dass ich das hier sage
ein fachidiot der sich fest genauso
festgefressen hat diesen diesem corona
maßnahmen ich finde gut dass er sich
stellt er stellt sich hat sich auch bei
bild vom paar tagen wieder gestellt und
auch erklärt zu der kritik daran nur ich
verstehe nicht es gibt doch jetzt nicht
plötzlich ein super grundrecht corona
schutz sondern es gibt doch auch andere
rechte warum bremst diesen mann
eigentlich niemand ein jahre alten aber
sie sind spd ab und das heißt karl
lauterbach aus der spd ist ja ihr
fraktionskollege ist meine
fraktionskollegen ist natürlich auch der
gesundheitsminister der bundesregierung
aber ich glaube nicht dass karl
lauterbach ein leben quasi das leben
unterschiedlich bewertet hat ja also
leben die von corona gerettet werden
können andere leben ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass er das so deutlich heute
gemacht hat und zu mal das ganz klar
gesagt hat gesagt also es gibt 100 bis
150 tote pro tag das sind viel zu viele
tot oder sich einig dass das e mail
einig das ist richtig hart aber wenn man
das natürlich jetzt zu ende führt also
dann ist auch 50 tote eigentlich 50 tote
zu viel also wohin will karl lauterbach
bis zu 0 toten das ist ein ehrbares ziel
aber es ist nicht einzuhalten und die
die die probleme die man hat wenn man
bis zu 0 corona toten am tag kommen
möchte ich schlief vergrößern sich auf
anderen bei anderen nicht immer absolut
soll während die krankenhaus problematik
die frau rebecca sie angesprochen hat
und da ist es ja so dass wir gerade die
regeln verändert haben das personal was
im gesundheitssektor arbeitet eben eine
verkürzte quarantäne hat oben um eben
dem sektor nicht personal zu entziehen
ja das mag vielleicht immer noch hart
sein nein bereiche doch ich will deine
uhr muss ich lachen weil jetzt will ich
hatte das jetzt in meiner praxis
tatsächlich auch und für medizinisches
personal gilt an fünf tage quarantäne
zeit für anderes personal was im büro
sitzt vielleicht auch alleine oder in
der regel in der lage ist auch menschen
zu vermeiden oder digital zu arbeiten
gilt sieben tage also wo ist da die
logik dass ich im büro oder in anderen
bereichen sieben tage quarantäne und
gesundheit gesundheitswesen wo ich
etliche menschen ihr aber die oma ist
einfach das quali nicht länger ein bild
das die auch die logik ist einfach so
dass quasi im bereich des
gesundheitswesens ich eine gewisse
vorsorge brauche eine versorgung mit
personal weiterhin und die aufrecht
erhalten muss auch in anderen bereichen
der daseinsvorsorge polizei wasserwerk
und so weiter und so fort sich da halt
sagen muss okay vielleicht wäre aus
medizinischer sicht eine andere tage
frist angemessen aber auch ganz
pragmatische sicht um das system
aufrecht zu halten muss ich sagen ich
gehe auf die fünf tage runter haben ein
konto lage fehler wenn die bisherige
grundlage nämlich die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems herr hagen ist es
dann gerechtfertigt diese maßnahmen
weiterhin aufrecht zu haben die wir
haben beispielsweise in einigen
bundesländern immer noch zwei gm handel
in den aller meisten bundesländern noch
zwei geht zum teil zweige plus in der
gastronomie ich halte diese ständigen
ziel verschiebung für hochproblematisch
wir haben am anfang wir erinnern uns
2020 gesagt das ziel ist flat und körper
also wir wollen die infektionsgefahr
abflachen dann hat es geheißen wollen
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
verhindern und jetzt heißt es sozusagen
jeder tote ist einer zu viel und das
durchdekliniert bedeutet dass wir kommen
nie mehr aus den maßnahmen raus und
deswegen glaube ich ist es vernünftig
und wir sagen es droht jetzt keine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems mir
dass wir auch von so maßnahmen wie zweig
möglich schnell bekommen aber wir haben
uns ja die pandemie bekämpfung auch die
politik diese pandemie bekämpfen mit
einer neuen bundesregierung ins
parlament zurück geholt bei der angela
merkel war das so dass wurde weiter
regierungssache auch verordnungen wurden
quasi von der bundesregierung
herausgegeben jetzt werden die
verordnung vom bundestag beschlossen und
haben dadurch natürlich eine viel höhere
legitimation die abgeordnete sind gerade
gewählt von der bevölkerung in der
pandemie zeit heißt sie haben ein mandat
dafür auch zu entscheiden das finde ich
sehr sehr demokratischen im märz werden
wir wieder darüber entscheiden und
darüber entscheiden wie wir die
maßnahmen verlängern und wir mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz weiter hervor
aber wir sehen ja um deutschland herum
gibt es immer mehr länder die ihre
maßnahmen zum teil sogar komplett
abschaffen und
jawohl deutschland sagt der
bundesgesundheitsminister auf keinen
fall es gibt jetzt nicht die zeit dafür
dies zu tun das ist schon sehr sehr
bitter die macht nicht bemerkenswert
aber meine familie dänisch und da ist es
eben so dass in der zielgruppe ab 60
jahren also die zielgruppe die einen
beiden nicht impfungen auch ein höheres
risiko hatten schweren verlauf zu haben
im krankenhaus zu lange auf der its zu
landen das wird dass wir dort eine
infektions dass wir dort eine impfrate
von 99 prozent haben da habe ich noch
eine andere grundlage als hier in
deutschland zu sagen ich schaffe diese
maßnahmen ab ich finde es auch schön
dass die dänen sehr flexibel mit diesen
regeln umgehen und sagen wirklich wir
lockern wenn es die situation nach
unserer bewertung ergibt und wir
verschärfen wir danach haben sie ja auch
gemacht quasi als die die lage eben
wieder nicht kontrollierbar war aber das
muss jedes land für sich bewerten und
wie gesagt die impfen lässt eine andere
aber um die logik von carlotta macht
dann einmal fortzuführen und martin
hagen hat ja gerade schon so ein
bisschen angedeutet würde eigentlich
bedeuten man müsste die zahl der toten
ob jetzt in der pandemie oder vielleicht
auch dann einem extrem harten grippe
winter natürlich immer wieder auf null
drücken am ende bedeutete dass ich darf
morgens eigentlich gar nicht aufstehen
ich formuliere es jetzt mal ganz ganz
salopp ganz klappt sich bei mir schon
beim aussteigen aus dem bett etwas
passieren könnte spätestens wenn ich auf
die straße gehe wie gesagt ganz wichtig
ich formuliere jetzt salopp könnte mich
ein auto umfahren mich könnt ein ziegel
treffen das kann ja nicht sinn und zweck
von politik sein zu sagen ich will das
risiko
körperlicher versehrtheit für jeden
menschen diesem land so ehrenwert dieses
ziel ist aber auf null reduzieren dann
würde dieses land komplett
zusammenbrechen es ist ja so also coruna
ist nicht grippe haben wir hier auch
immer wieder klargestellt nur es ist ja
so mir graut davor mal einfach als
gedankenspiel was wäre wenn die politik
jetzt plötzlich drauf kommt wir bringen
euch jetzt auch noch gut durch die
nächste grippewelle weiter sterben du
eben noch 20.000 menschen oder teilweise
auch mehr das nicht bezahlen das ist ein
oft so gar nicht bewusst gewesen wie
schlimm auch die die grippe er sein kann
wie die wütet gerade bei der firma
10.000 euro in krippe trainer enorme
zahlen und dennoch machen wir das da
nicht das ist die frage warum machen wir
das bei corona bei corona irgendwie neu
ist ein cola ist jetzt ja auch gar nicht
mehr so neue koma wird auch nicht wieder
verschwinden wahrscheinlich das wird ja
das wird eine erkrankung sein die man
sich eben einfangen kann deswegen ist es
mir persönlich wichtig geimpft und
gebuchter zu sein tatsächlich das ist
aber im übrigen auch was wo ich mal
sagen muss dass ich geimpft und gepustet
bin das ist eine sache für mich
eigentlich zwischen mir und meinem arzt
und nicht zwischen mir und meinem
imbissbesitzer oder so dem ich jedes mal
wieder das zeigen muss
auch das finde ich sollte jetzt langsam
sehr schnell sollte das enten es ist
auch nicht dienlich nach meiner meinung
dem infektionsschutz
ich finde wir haben uns in dieser
politik völlig verlaufen ja also es ist
absurd was wir veranstalten wenn ich mir
überlege dass wir wirklich immer nur
noch über irgendwelche corona zahlen
sprechen corona tote wo keiner wirklich
auch verifiziert wann ist ein crooner
toter wirklich ein crooner tod an was
ist ja wirklich gestorben dass es das
gibt dass das schlimm ist dass wir das
behandeln müssen das ist doch jetzt
lange seit zwei jahren diskutiert aber
was hier völlig vergessen und das ist
das was ich täglich in der praxis sehe
ist dass es natürlich genau wie sie
sagen andere dinge gibt wir haben kinder
die psychisch traumatisiert sind wir den
ganzen tag mit diesem verrückten masken
im unterricht sitzen ärger bekommen wenn
sie am fenster sitzen die mütze auf
haben wir haben menschen die depressiv
sind wir haben menschen die ihren job
verloren haben wir haben existenzen die
brach liegen und wir laufen in eine
wirtschaftliche situation zurück von
keiner von uns hier am tisch sitzend
noch überdenken kann und das finde ich
maximal verteilt das ist ein sonderweg
ein deutscher sonderweg kann man fast
sagen herr hagen dass es genau das
stichwort glaube ich für sie heute abend
ja richtig
dänemark spanien norwegen israel
großbritannien immer mehr länder auf der
welt beenden ihre corona maßnahmen in
deutschland hingegen erklärte
gesundheitsminister die diskussion über
lockerungen sei fehl am platz in ganz
europa gilt eu-weit eingelesenen status
sechs monate lang in deutschland erklärt
das lka er gilt nur dreimal und auch bei
der impfpflicht gerät deutschland
zunehmend in eine isolation die
allgemeine impfpflicht gibt es nur in
einem land in europa nämlich in
österreich in den anderen ländern ist
sie noch nicht mal ein thema und ich
fordere schluss mit diesem deutschen
corona sonderweg ja die ampel macht eine
bessere pandemie politik als die
vorgängerregierung ich glaube unter
merkel werden wir alle seit weihnachten
im lockt das ist gut dass wir das
verhindert haben aber das reicht nicht
mehr kroner verändert die lage und
deswegen muss sich auch die politik
verändern wir müssen jetzt schrittweise
zurück in die normalität andere länder
können das und ich glaube wir können er
ist ein interessanter punkt deutscher
sonderweg dass es gibt sie in vielen
politischen bereichen deutschland war
auch zu beginn der pandemie da meiner
auffassung auf einem sonderweg da hatte
man nämlich den eindruck das ausland hat
schon maßnahmen ergriffen hygiene
konzept begabt am flughafen
beispielsweise bei uns war nix dahinter
dann plötzlich mal irgendwie am
flughafen mal so ein plakat oder gibt es
dieses neuartigen corona virus auf juan
oder so man hat sich gefragt wann wachen
wir auf wann ergreifen wir maßnahmen
jetzt sind wir in diesem modus dass wir
maßnahmen haben und jetzt kommen wir
davon aber nicht wieder runter dass das
verstehe ich nicht also hatte man war
erst spät dran sozusagen sich an die
neue realität anzupassen jetzt sind wir
sozusagen ancona irgendwie angepasst
jetzt schaffen wir es aber nicht wieder
nicht davon runter zu kommen weil wir
uns an die an die veränderte realität
auch nicht anpassen offensichtlich
nämlich dass das omikron die omikron
variante gott sei dank nicht so schlimm
ist und milde verläufe macht und bei
vielen nur an schnupfen teilweise ja
auch wenn wir wenn wir gucken in den
zweier zweiten drittel hatte deutschland
mit die strengsten maßnahmen überhaupt
in europa kein land sonst hat solange
die schulen geschlossen nicht darüber
gesprochen die materialschäden für
schülerinnen und schüler an dramatisch
das heißt wir haben immer wieder einen
besonders harten weg gewählt wie wir
jetzt merken war das noch nicht mal der
erfolgreichste kurs und wir gucken
welche schäden sind sondern verhindert
worden und ich glaube jetzt ist es
dringend an der zeit dass wir auch die
politik auf die neue situation anpassen
nikon ist eben anders als delta und
andere länder haben das früher
verstanden uns wir brauchen wir einen
freedom day hagen so wie es
beispielsweise auch dänemark in der
vergangenen woche ein zweites mal
durchgeführt hat und exerziert wir
müssen natürlich das ziel am zurück zur
normalität zu kommen ob das an einem tag
basiert oder ob man das schrittweise
macht glaube das muss man dann abwägen
aber das ziel kann ja nicht sein dass
wir diese maßnahmen jetzt immer weiter
führen dass wir jetzt dass sie haben
gesagt in jeder grippewelle
möglicherweise unsere impf ausweise
vorzeigen wenn wir ins restaurant gehen
dass wir zugangsbeschränkungen machen in
kultur sport und anderen veranstaltungen
sondern das ziel muss sein ich möchte
dass wenn corona ruhmes und nicht in dem
sinne dass verschwindet corona wird
nicht verschwinden wir müssen da mit dem
virus zu leben oder wenn die gefahr der
überforderung des gesundheitssystems
vorbei ist dann möchte ich dass wir
wieder genau so leben wie wir das vor
corinna getan haben ich hab den
bundeskanzler mitgebracht nächste woche
ist ja wieder ein bund länder gipfel ein
corona gipfel morgen mittwoch in einer
woche und wir haben das thema friede
becker angesprochen ich möchte einmal
die runde fragen fällt auch sie hält
ihren bundeskanzler brauchen wir in
freedom day was muss passieren am
kommenden mittwoch beim und länder
gipfel ich bin's hatte die chance ist
dem kanzler direkt zu sagen völlig einig
mit manchen hagen dass wir wieder zurück
zur normalität müssen aber vielleicht
nicht nächste woche wie gesagt die
impfquote bei uns ist wesentlich
schlechter als in den ländern die jetzt
in freedom day haben und darum und darum
müssen wir das ganz ganz genau abwägen
okay was muss passieren
antwort an den kanzler jetzt einmal was
plus nächsten mittwoch auf dem bund
länder gipfel passieren welche maßnahmen
müssten gelockert werden vielleicht
sogar weg dann gebe ich jetzt keine
ratschläge an olaf scholz das mussten
die entscheiden die wird die
verantwortung haben der bundestag
beschäftigt sich wieder märz damit auch
wir das infektionsschutzgesetz
verlängern mit diesen maßnahmen will
sagen nein wir bewerten das anders dann
sind diese maßnahmen alle nicht mehr
möglich dafür braucht eine gesetzliche
ermächtigung und bei der impfpflicht
sehen sie ja auch die abgeordneten das
ernst wenn sie die umfragen sehen auch
der welt letzte woche dass die leute
sehr differenziert sind der meinung
machen darüber welche anträge auf dem
tisch liegen also wie wir corona
bekämpfen möchten und welche welchem
antrag sie sich dann auch zustimmen
möchten deshalb nehme ich an meine
kollegen und ich wir betrachten das
differenziert aber wir wir lockern und
wir nehmen maßnahmen weg wenn es noch
zeit ist frau rehbein sie sitzen nicht
im bundestag hat trotzdem die chance den
bundeskanzler jetzt einmal zu sagen was
muss mittwoch in einer woche passiert
auf dem geländer gipfel also ich sehe
ich so als nicht politikerin und als
normale bürgerin unternehmerin des
landes habe ich mittlerweile seit zwei
jahren das gefühl dass die politiker
sich gar nicht mehr trauen ich habe mal
wieder die verantwortung haben es
übernimmt doch gar keiner verantwortung
das gefühl kommt auf das keiner mehr
traut sich was zu ändern weil es haben
wir zwei jahre lang der bevölkerung so
viel zugemutet und so viele tolle regeln
aufgestellt die alle in die völlig im
sande verlaufen nämlich befolgt werden
können von überhaupt von land zu land
bundeslands wurde auch noch
unterschiedlich sind und irgendwie
beschleicht ein so das gefühl dass das
das land überhaupt gar keine richtige
führung mehr hat das nur so dahin
plätschern und verantwortung übernehmen
tut keiner sondern wir machen einfach so
weiter wie es ist weil also wir alle
würde ich als unternehmerin mein
unternehmen sofern welchen insolvent wie
wir teilweise hier das land führen
sebastian du bist politischer beobachter
als bild redakteur für politik und wird
schafft von daher deine botschaft
kanzler ich würde aber sagen herr scholz
wie begründen sie denn überhaupt dass
die maßnahmen noch gelten ist müsste ja
automatismus sein dass wenn keine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems mehr
droht wenn wir jetzt auch sehr viel mehr
wissen über krone als vor zwei jahren
das dann solche maßnahmen fallen das ist
eigentlich unser gutes recht ich möchte
wissen warum er sich raus nimmt unser
recht auf unsere freiheit einzuschränken
heran wann muss der frieden beck kommt
man sollte olaf scholz hinaus rufen olaf
scholz braucht den film da überhaupt
nicht auszurufen dann die krone politik
wird maßgeblich in den ländern bestimmt
wir haben einen infektionsschutzgesetz
dass die ampel gemacht hat dass den
ländern einen instrumentenkasten zur
verfügung stellt den können sie
ausschöpfen auch sie müssen die nicht
ausschöpfen und zum beispiel in bayern
hat man bisher besonders strenge regeln
wir hatten eine sperrstunde um 22 uhr
die wird jetzt abgeschafft nicht durch
olaf scholz sondern durch die bayerische
regierung und so sollte jedes bundesland
schauen wo sie wieder mehr freiheit
ermöglichen können dann die situation
gibt das momentan hier ist es überfällig
sie kommen aus bayern frau rehbein ist
überfällig dass dort gar nicht wird oder
steigen sie anders gefragt eigentlich
noch durch man hat mal den eindruck ein
bayern prescht vor in die eine richtung
da wieder die an richtung ich habe ich
muss gestehen ich hatte es heute schon
erzählt ich bin jetzt frisch mami
erstmal wieder essen gegangen letzten
samstag polieren und herzlich danke 22
uhr kam der wirt und sagte jüngsten
gehen sie müssen gehen und habe ich
gedacht ich hab das verbrauchen sich
sowieso was jetzt gemacht und ich hatte
das gar nicht mehr auf schirm bisher in
schwörstadt immerhin ja bis 22 sowie ein
kleines dünnes mädchen wirst du nach
hause geschickt als wenn ich keine
einfach nur überleben wird von
demokratie wo ist da die demokratie dar
wie die kann man das überhaupt noch
rechtfertigen ich fühle mich so was von
bevormundet dass sie um 22 uhr nach
hause geschickt werde und ich kann das
als bürgerin überhaupt nicht mehr
akzeptieren mit den jetzigen ich
verstehe sie dass sie vielleicht ein
überblick verloren haben also meine
lehre aus der pandemie wäre wenn wir mal
wieder so eine pandemie haben die
führung durch bundesebene ich finde es
auf der name ist eben nichts zu suchen
für das ganze land einheitliche regeln
dann weiß man auch wenn die aufhören die
in kraft gesetzt werden wenn die außer
kraft treten und dass unsere sache die
müssen wir uns anschauen also jeder der
eigentlich führungen ein bisschen
versteht der weiß es bringt nichts wenn
16 leute führen und dann muss eben einer
führen muss auch einer die verantwortung
wieder angebote in sachsen
sie sagen franco diktatur aber wenn ich
immer einen geben was mal auf die
interstate wenn die imb in sachsen bei
unter 70 prozent ist in bremen aber bei
deutlich über 90 prozent dann soll
trotzdem in sachsen und bremen die
gleichen bedingungen die gleichen corona
maßnahmen greifen das machen andere
länder ja auch bedienen sie uns sonst ja
auch so gerne vergleichen ich finde es
auf jeden fall eine größere
nachvollziehbarkeit regeln welche regel
gilt hier jetzt und nicht jeder
landkreis entscheidet wie es am anfang
hat man dass jeder landkreis quasi die
korona maßnahmen noch nachgeschärft hat
wird da widersprechen ich bin
überzeugter föderalist und ich glaube
dass es sich durchaus bewährt dass wir
in deutschland auch unterschiedliche
regeln hatten wir haben dadurch auch
gesehen welche regeln wirken und welche
nicht schon sie bayern hatte fast
durchgehend die strengsten regeln sie
hatten aber meistens die schlechtesten
zahlen das heißt wir konnten sehen dass
solche sachen wie diese bayerische
ausgangssperre oder jetzt die korona
sperrstunden 20 uhr dass die eben nicht
geholfen haben und wir haben gesehen
dass andere länder wie zum beispiel die
länder wo die fdp den
gesundheitsminister stellt schließlich
holstein mit milde und regeln bessere
ergebnisse gebracht haben und deswegen
glaube ich brauche wieder kein
zentralismus und wir brauchen insgesamt
einfach wieder mehr augenmaß in dieser
corona politik ist eigentlich aus ihrer
sicht die allgemeine impfpflicht fast
schon tot wenn wir sie kommen aus bayern
sehen was der bayerische
ministerpräsident gestern angekündigt
hatte er gesagt hat dass die impfpflicht
für pfleger für ärzte erst mal de facto
ausgesetzt wird also nicht umgesetzt
werden soll dann ist ja die große frage
was passiert eigentlich mit der
allgemeinen pflicht der witz ist ja
markus söder war der große befürworter
der einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
jetzt ist sie da jetzt sagt wir setzen
sie nicht um aber gleichzeitig fordert
er dass auf bundesebene eine allgemeine
impfpflicht für alle kommen muss ich
halte es für ein totes pferd ich glaube
dass es mit der nikon variante nicht
mehr zu rechtfertigen ist denn wir
wissen ja dass wir das virus nicht
ausrotten werden weil geimpfte und
ungeimpfte beide das virus auch weiter
übertragen können das heißt mit dem ziel
einer ausrottung der krankheit kann man
sowas nicht begründen und wir haben
momentan auch nicht die befürchtung dass
die kliniken überlastet werden und wenn
wir die befürchtung hätten dann wäre das
auch kein argument für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht weil er die klinik und nicht
durch die 18 20 30 40 jährige überlastet
werden sondern insbesondere durch die
über 60 über 70-jährigen das heißt damit
könnte man allenfalls eine
altersabhängige impfpflicht begründen
ich glaube aber dass das thema impfen
generell vom tisch sollte ich glaube wir
brauchen das nicht wir haben übrigens
auch bei den älteren bruder von 90 ist
nicht so dass wir da lauter ungeimpfte
hätten also sehr herald martinhagen
jetzt im bundestag dann würde er
vehement gegen die allgemeine
impfpflicht auch argumentieren debatte
die ja offenbar nächste woche
stattfinden soll xbox die erste lesung
geht das ganze gesetz der ausschuss wird
dort fachlich diskutiert aber wir wissen
ja noch gar nicht welche vorschläge
vorliegen haben meine drei vorschläge
die parteiübergreifend vorliegen oder
den vierten noch von der afg okay und es
sind noch zwei weitere zu erwarten
nächste woche als wir haben dann sechs
vorschläge nachdem für die jeder
abgeordnete stimmen kann und von denen
einer die mehrheit auf sich vereinen
muss wird noch spannend aber es ist doch
eigentlich schon rohrkrepierer dieser
allgemeine impfpflicht oder nicht das
würde ich sagen wenn die abstimmung
gelaufen dass wir haben den die debatte
ja noch gar nicht geführt die ist noch
nicht zu ende geführt aber wie wollen
sie eine allgemeine impfpflicht denn
eigentlich argumentieren wenn man
eigentlich immer nur hinterher impft
also wenn man jetzt ein impfstoff hat
beispielsweise der gegen die data
variante hilft aber gar nicht bei
omikron wenn man dann im herbst impft
gegen beispielsweise die omikron
variante die aber dann im herbst gar
nicht mehr existiert sondern überlagert
ist ich sage jetzt mal von einer
ehrlichen variante wie auch immer ich
habe auch gar nicht für die eine andere
variante gesprochen ich bin mir
natürlich noch eine meinung denn wenn du
noch nicht mal alle vorschläge auf den
tisch legen wenn ich mich nicht
hinstellen und sagen ich bin vor warnte
variante a b oder c das wäre unfair da
kommen noch 2 3 und dann werde ich
entscheiden wie ich abstimmen hat zwar
noch nicht wir sollten übrigens nicht
sagen die impfung hilft nicht gegen
dominik ron also sie hilft die höheren
verlauf ja es ist ein sehr guter
eigenschutz die impfung aber sie hilft
eben nicht oder sie schützt nicht davor
dass man sich infiziert sie schützt
nicht davor dass man das virus weiter
gibt und das ist der punkt damit ist
auch die impfpflicht eigentlich nicht
mehr wirklich begründen sicherlich auch
nicht vor erkrankungen also wir haben
natürlich auch genug geimpfte die auch
erkranken und auch immer noch einen
schweren verlauf haben und da muss man
sich auch wirklich fangen wie weit kann
ich einer bevölkerung dann zumuten
impfpflicht zu haben für eine impfung
die eben nicht verhindert die nicht
ausreichend wirklich schützt so was zu
auf zu doktor ihren ist es am ende des
tages finde ich schon schwierig
impfpflicht und dann gleichzeitig das
vertrauen in die politik das ist das
stichwort für sebastian geisler er
wollte einfach mal sagen schluss mit der
ideologie in der politik wir haben in
deutschland ein problem und das ist dass
viele politische maßnahmen gas
unterschied ideologisch motiviert und
begründet sind das betrifft zum beispiel
die energiewende wo deutschland als
einziges land der welt aus steigt
gleichzeitig aus boston in den trägern
und aus der atomkraft und sowohl die
merkel regierung als auch jetzt die
ampel stellt sich hin verbreitet dass
noch stolz dass die ganze welt uns
erfolgen würde in wahrheit folgt uns
niemand warum war der deutsche sonderweg
ein holzweg ist in dem fall um vier sind
wieder mal auf dem holzweg an der stelle
das ist eine simulation unwürdig dass
wir abhängig sind von stromimporten zum
beispiel oder von punkt ins russen gas
das darf nicht sein das betrifft aber
auch die migrationspolitik wenn ich
jetzt höre dass innenministerin nancy
faeser eine koalition der willigen
schmieden will mit deutschland als
vorbild deutschland geht wieder mutig
voran will möglichst offenbar migranten
im ausland ja man hat ja fast den
eindruck noch an werben obwohl wir nicht
mal die probleme die mit der
flüchtlingskrise 2015 folgende gekommen
sind tatsächlich schlüssig bewältigt
haben da fährt an doch nichts mehr zu da
will uns das ausland offensichtlich auch
nicht folgen weil wir hier sozusagen der
geisterfahrer sind an der stelle und so
geht s so geht es weiter militante
demonstranten die krankenwagen
blockieren hier in berlin menschen die
sich auf die straße kleben und glauben
sie würden damit unser essen retten das
ist ja man soll das nicht pathologisiert
aber das ist ja näher nahe einer
psychose denn an einer politischen
programmatik irgendwie orientiert und
dafür gibt es dann sogar noch
schützenhilfe zum front zum beispiel
grünen-chefin ricarda lang die auch noch
sagt sie hat auch verständnis dafür dass
ist dieses untergangs geräte wenn wir
nicht in drei jahren irgendwie aufhören
unser altglas mit dem auto zum
supermarkt um zum also zum
altglascontainer weg zu fahren dann geht
die welt unter so das ist doch alles
quatsch wir brauchen endlich wieder eine
realpolitik eine politik die vernünftig
ist und die sich orientiert tatsächlich
an dem was die breite der gesellschaft
braucht und da gibt es ja genug zu zu
besprechen auch beispielsweise
wohneigentum ist für die mittelschicht
sehr schwer noch zu erreichen die die
hohen energiepreise der teuer schock das
sind alles themen
ja also muss ich sagen ein tolles medley
herr geißler was sie da gemacht haben
durch alle politikbereiche und ich würde
sagen die neue realpolitik ist man
fortschritt wagen wir haben von angela
merkel in ganz ganz nah verkrustetes
verstaubt das land übernommen was in
vielen
im bereich ein modernisierungsbedarf hat
sei es in der energiepolitik wir müssen
raus aus der kohleverstromung wir müssen
auch raus aus dem atomstrom oder folgen
uns viele europäische länder vielleicht
nicht frankreich in diesem fall aber
viele andere länder die das auch
kritisch sehen wir haben die zwar die
höchsten strompreise und wenn sie sagen
die sind abhängig vom russen gas dann
ist das so dass russland selbst zu
zeiten des kalten krieges immer
pünktlich seine energie viel lieferung
abgeliefert hat und das was vertraglich
vereinbart war geliefert hat natürlich
müssen wir diversifizieren da bin ich
mit ihm völlig einig müssen energie aus
mehr quellen kaufen und es wäre schön
wenn wir auf unter 50 prozent kommen
würden mit den russischen gaslieferungen
aber die russischen gaslieferungen
kommen und auf die kann man sich
verlassen und dafür brauchen wir auch
noch zum 2 migrations politik sie haben
es angesprochen und sie frau wäber
indiens von auch fachkräftemangel ja es
will ja keiner im krankenhaus arbeiten
ich habe mehrere termine mit den ihk es
in mecklenburg vorpommern gehabt überall
werden fachkräfte gesucht wir brauchen
also eine unbürokratische anwerbung von
fachkräften die zu uns kommen bei den
auch die qualifikationen anerkannt
werden und wir ohne die unsere
wirtschaft gar nicht mehr in gang halten
können und auch das warum nicht mal
jeder kunde ja sie reden von angela
merkel die ein verstaubtes land
hinterlassen hat wenn ich mich recht
entsinne mag sein dass ich falsch liege
hat die spd in den letzten 16 jahren
angela merkel an zwölf jahren mitregiert
in zwölf jahren mitregiert also seit
2005 zwölf jahre lang war die spd mit
dabei unterbrochen 2009 bis 2013 von
einer schwarz gelben koalition das heißt
sie waren ja immer mit dabei das heißt
die spd dieses land ja mit eingestaubt
muss man wirklich so sagen und beim
thema energie und als kleinerer
koalitionspartner auch nicht immer
durchsetzen den sozialen dingen haben
wir das getan wir haben familien gelten
eingeführt dann dem mindestlohn
eingeführt aldinger waren der spd
problem programmatik aber vielleicht hat
das zur versteuerung des landes mit
beigetragen vielleicht erst aber einmal
ganz kurz zu thema ich das sagen darf
beim thema energie wundert mich immer
die argumentation vor allem von spd
politikern aber auch von grünen
politikern die gar nicht sehen wollen in
welches drama wir hinein laufen wir
sollen den anteil der stromerzeugung
noch mal fast um 50 prozent erhöhen von
560 terawattstunden pro jahr auf 730
ungefähr im jahr 20 30 von neun jahren
gleichzeitig berauben wir uns ungefähr
50 prozent dessen was wir an um
erzeugung haben konventionelle kohle was
rui auch sinnvoll ist und kernkraft das
heißt wenn wir das reduzieren brauchen
wir eigentlich 100 prozent wir brauchen
200 prozent mehr
kapazität für stromerzeugung wie soll
das eigentlich in neun jahren
funktionieren und der hinweis deswegen
steigen aus der kernkraft aus dass
einmal richtig ist der ist das ist ja
kein argument also wir gehen jetzt
sehenden auges in ein echtes drama rein
wollen wir zum dritten mal entscheiden
dass wir die kernkraft jetzt drin
bleiben also der lösungsvorschlag der
haben lösungsvorschlag der kabel ist der
lösungsvorschlag der ampel ist es ein
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
ausbau der netze der erneuerbaren
energien photovoltaik windkraft und so
weiter auch kraftvoll vorantreiben zu
können und wir brauchen gas als
brückentechnologie und brauchen dafür
auch die leitungs infrastruktur und
darum ist auch wichtig es noch 72 ans
netz geht aber noch zum 2 ist gas wo es
auch protest gibt dass das noch nicht so
ganz klimaneutrales trotzdem aber die
frage technologie können sie versprechen
dass
die ampel ist schafft die erzeugung die
nötig ist also das ganze über 200
prozent zu steigern bis 2030 versprechen
kann ich das jetzt natürlich nicht an
diesem kurs werden sich einfach das zu
tun aber wir werden alles dafür tun dass
es so schnell unbürokratisch wie möglich
von ihrer lehrerin freuen wenn sie wenn
sie nicht weiß ob sie sich um kriegt und
zu welchem preis oder ich muss langsam
nur noch lachen hier ehrlich gesagt das
ist hier ist es wissen wieso die die wie
es wirklich in der politik funktioniert
da wird nämlich immer viel geredet und 4
geplant und viele planungsvorschläge
gemacht und vorschlag des vorschlag des
vorschlags und es passiert einfach viel
zu wenig natürlich ist das toll aus der
atomkraft auszusteigen und da bin ich
auch eine befürworterin aber doch erst
wenn wir im plan haben wie es danach
weitergeht wie sollen wir das denn
machen und spätestens jetzt merkte es
auch der letzte bürger weil jetzt ist es
gewinne plötzlich groß über die hohen
strompreise herzlichen glückwunsch das
ist politisch gemacht wirtschaftlich
leider überhaupt nicht mehr stemmbar und
nicht umsonst im stand jetzt im wall
street journal dass deutschland die
dümmste
strompolitik aller zeiten hat und das
kann ich nur so unterschreiben es ist
ehrenwert zu sagen wir wollen das klima
schützen aber es muss auch machbar sein
atomkraft ist ja also noch
funktionierende atomkraftwerke wie wir
es ja zum jahreswechsel gemacht haben zu
nehmen drei in einer energiekrise zum
einen angesichts der höchsten
strompreise der welt und die ja
sozusagen co2 neutralen laufen das halte
ich tatsächlich wirklich für pure
ideologie das war doch ein fehler das
war und ist ein pro kilowattstunde
kosten der produktion wenn wir die
lagerung und den betrieb mit einrechnen
die vom steuerzahler finanziert wird
werden eine in erneuerbare energie
kilowattstunde 7 cent kosten deutliche
preisunterschiede
heute noch heute entscheiden müssten
glaube ich würde mir alle sagen wir
steigen erst aus der kohle raus und
steigen dann aus der atomkraft auch die
reihenfolge aber falsch aber sagen
damals hat man in deutschland das waren
eine mehrheit über mehrere jahrzehnte
mac stabil etwa drei viertel der
bevölkerung die ein atomausstieg wollten
ein und er haben jetzt machen sie sich
zu leicht nein die schwarz gelbe
koalition hat im herbst 2010 den
atomausstieg von rot-grün rückgängig
gemacht hat gesagt ja
dann um einfach wirklich die geschichte
so zu erzählen wie sie ist gab es ein
tsunami über
10.000 kilometer entfernt und auf grund
der tsunami angst die man offen auch in
deutschland hat hat man gesagt jetzt
steigen wir hier aus es gab überhaupt
keinen grund hier auszusteigen ich werde
die unter schwarz-gelb ich werde den
ausstieg nicht rechtfertigen weil ich
wie gesagt ich halte die reihenfolge für
falsch werden erst raus aus der kohle
sollen und dann irgendwann raus aus der
atomkraft aber es war eine breite
gesellschaftliche mehrheit über viele
jahrzehnte hinweg spätestens seit den
80er jahren seit dem atom unglück in der
ukraine die gewollte dass wir in
deutschland aussteigen und jetzt merken
wir dass es geht nicht so einfach die
preise steigen wir werden strom
importieren wir werden auf strom aus
kernkraftwerken in frankreich
importieren und das wird die neue
realität sein wir werden uns in
deutschland nicht autark mit strom
versorgen was aber auch kein drama ist
ich glaube wir brauchen insgesamt mehr
europäischen energiemarkt mit vielen
netzen weil wir können solarstrom sehr
günstig irgendwo in südspanien
produzieren wir können anderen küstenort
europa sehr günstig strom aus wind strom
produzieren aber der strom musste an
ihrem einkommen nur gefahren ist das
eigentlich kein problem atomstrom aus
frankreich zu importieren aber eigenen
atomstrom in deutschland herzustellen
gut wir haben immer wir mussten immer
strom importieren ja das war immer schon
der fall also es wäre unseren
strombedarf nicht selber decken konnten
und natürlich wäre es schöner wir
müssten diese atomstrom nicht aus
frankreich importieren aber das ist dann
okay
frankreich
realität zumindest ja ob das okay so
nachfrage
oder kabel strom aus braun zum beispiel
da muss man auch sagen das hilft dem
klima nicht will hätten wir besser noch
auf unseren atomstrom gesetzt in dem
fall ja hat man nicht das gefühl dass
die politik dem problem immer
hinterherrennt ja also ich höre ist es
für über viele jahre schon eigentlich
absehbar gewesen es funktioniert nicht
es muss erst immer so zum totalen
zusammenbruch kommen ist es so gar
nichts mehr geht bis dann mal kommt
vielleicht müssen wir überdenken
brauchen wir ein plan b ich finde das
eigentlich fatale also tatsächlich würde
man unternehmen so führen gibt es keine
mehr ist muss man mal ganz klar so sagen
und wir sind ja auch nicht ganz ehrlich
ist wird ja vom steuerzahler finanziert
wenn ich jetzt ihr sollt
heizkostenzuschuss geben wer zahlt das
denn alles das zahlen die steuerzahler
und jetzt heißt es schon 180 euro sind
zu wenig 270 euro sind zu wenig jetzt
wird gefordert 500 euro heizkosten
errechnet dass man hoch auf die
gesamtbevölkerung das ist doch ein
irrsinn was wir hier machen würden sie
eigentlich die politik gehen ja ich
glaube ich würde wahrscheinlich tot im
straßengraben nach einer woche legen
heute nicht erträglich wäre meine zu
aber so ehrlich ist soll es mehr
unternehmen politik gehen und es werden
doch gerade unternehmerinnen unternehmer
in der politik dass jemand ich verstehe
dass sie haben sie habe nicht so
furchtbar viel zeit sich diesem hobby zu
widmen falls sie im unternehmen zu
leiten aber eigentlich bräuchten wir den
parlamenten mehr leute mit unternehmer
erfahrung und er hat beide kommen wir
aus bgh der aus der nähe von münchen
möglicherweise im nachhinein
und gleich ein kandidat kanadas 22 23
was hat sie eigentlich bewogen in die
politik zu gehen ich bin relativ viel in
der welt unterwegs gewesen auch
beruflich habe in stockholm gelebt ich
hab in tel aviv gelebt also hab einige
länder gesehen war auch im
auslandseinsatz und wenn man dann wenn
man als soldaten afghanistan normal
jetzt feststellen das telefon eines
mobilfunk netz funktioniert wesentlich
besser am einsatz von haus in
mecklenburg vorpommern dann ist das eine
sache wo ich sage okay dinge die kann
ich nicht akzeptieren ich möchte vor
allem dass mehr chancen dass wir
wirklich im 21 jahrhundert ankommen ich
habe gesagt ich mein mann ist dänisch
ich kann mich per telefon jetzt hier
scheiden lassen per app kann man ja
darüber diskutieren ob man es gut findet
aber es geht also ein
handy das nicht also das gehört zu den
23 prozent der verwaltung mit dem handy
gehen aber ich finde einfach wir müssen
im 21 jahrhundert ankommen und das sind
dinge die mich ärgern und sie sagen
zurecht gewarnt dass wenn sie in
unternehmen wie die bundesrepublik
führen würde das vielleicht bleibt er
wäre aber es ist doch auch so will ich
irgendwo mobilfunk max aufstellen gibt
es protest ja also sind auch riesig wir
müssen auch sehen dass wir diesen
fortschritt implementiert kriegen und
auch schnell implementiert kriegen weil
wir können nicht jeden straßenkilometer
jede leitung jeden mast diskutieren bis
ins unendliche und das fünfmal beklagen
lassen es geht nicht wie ein bisschen
recht vorankommen ich habe meinem
wahlkreis der stadt haben sich vor 150
jahren entschieden sie möchten keine
eisenbahn haben weil die eisenbahnen
gefährlich wäre die liebe ich auch dran
die leiden wollen auch daran dass der
bund diese von der hauptstrecke wechsel
waren da und herren wir haben jetzt
diskutiert über corona über was sonst
können sie wahrscheinlich oder werden
sie auch sagen wir haben diskutiert über
die frage wie glaubwürdig ist eigentlich
deutsche politik noch und nach der
kurzen pause da geht es weiter mit zwei
wirklich spannenden themen es geht unter
anderem auch um putin und die ukraine
bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich ein lauter krach und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zum viertel nach acht gegentoren
der schlagend sein machen mein name ist
relativ
so nicht privatjet buschi hätten seit
august aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russland die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
derart zu überlassen lasst den leuten
noch mal einen spaß wir sehen ja etwas
was eigentlich fatale ist in der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade hat beide meinungen zu
führen und sie sollen den doch auch
wichtig dürften
noch etliche andere träger aus kommt in
bewegung bringt ich hab mein beifahrer
eine sache immer bekommt er kümmert sich
darum niemand gibt es bei federer man
muss da ganz kleine auch darüber
sprechen ganz klein sagt nicht der hat
mich richtig ist die konnte medien nicht
beklagen nur noch vier wochen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück bei viertel
nach acht dem tag der schlagzeilen macht
bei mir im studio johannes als spd
bundestagsabgeordneter und offizier
william rehbein fachärztin unternehmerin
mein sehr geschätzter bild kollege
sebastian geisler martinhagen
fdp-fraktionschefin bayern ich bin jan
schäfer und wir haben schon heiß
diskutiert und es geht gleich weiter wie
tore bei
deutschland wird die unternehmer immer
unattraktiver
eine neue umfrage ergab dass 15 prozent
der deutschen in erwägung ziehen ins
ausland auszuwandern ich als
unternehmerin muss mittlerweile gestehen
dass ich das sehr gut verstehen kann
denn nicht nur die derzeitige oder seit
zwei jahren bestehende corona politik
und die krone maßnahmen machen zwischen
unternehmer schier unmöglich noch
wirtschaftlich zu arbeiten
auch unsere bürokratie die ins
unendliche geht dieses steuersystem ich
sag nur zehn steuerberater 10
steuererklärungen machen dass
wirtschaftlicher arbeiten für uns
unternehmer mit freude zunehmend
schwerer ein ganz anderer punkt ist noch
die digitalisierung in deutschland wo
wir wirklich auf einem absoluten
rückständigen punkt im moment angekommen
sind wodurch wir wirklich in vielen
bereichen nicht mehr vorwärts kommen
rohstoffmangel steigende strompreise die
wir gerade diskutiert haben behindern
das wirtschaftliche fortkommen und
führen dazu dass ich als unternehmerin
tatsächlich über nachdenke ob nicht
andere standorte mittlerweile
attraktiver sind und es macht mich im
herzen eigentlich traurig
kann ich gut verstehen und ich glaube
sie haben wichtigen punkt weil all das
was wir uns auch in der politik
vornehmen wir wollen deutschland
klimaneutral gestalten wir wollen mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit das funktioniert
ja alles nur mit einer starken
wirtschaft irgendjemand muss ja das
ganze wirtschaft muss das ganze
finanzieren aber die themen angesprochen
haben da hat sich glaube ich die ampel
im koalitionsvertrag schon einiges
vorgenommen stichwort fachkräfte wir
wollen jetzt ein echtes
einwanderungsgesetz dass auch
deutschland attraktiv macht für
qualifizierte fachkräfte gewonnen
gleichzeitig die hürden für geflüchtete
in den arbeitsmarkt abbauen damit ihr
nicht zum nichtstun verdammt werden
stichwort energie wir werden die
eeg-umlage abschaffen auf den strompreis
ist auch wieder für unternehmen gut
stichwort planungs beschleunigung der
wahlen ist gerade infrastrukturprojekte
schneller realisiert werden wir wollen
in die digitalisierung investieren und
wirtschaft eine super abschreibungen das
unternehmen auch anreize haben in
klimafreundliche und digitale
technologien zu investieren das heißt
das thema ihr haben wir die wirtschaft
in schwung spielt für die ampeln eine
große rolle das klingt alles immer so
supertoll das problem ist nur auf
politischer ebene mag das alles so ein
aber ich lebe in der realität und arbeit
in brand und erwirtschafte unmengen an
steuern und kann nur sagen das
funktioniert ja alles und ich wirklich
am ende des tages nämlich so aus dass
wir fast keine mittelstand mehr haben
ist für uns mittelständler die mit wie
ich ein praxis inhaberin versucht sich
irgendwie durch diesen dschungel durch
zu navigieren mehr damit beschäftigt bin
das bürokratische zu erledigen oder
meine steuererklärung über monate weg zu
machen vorauszahlungen zu machen zu
stemmen mitarbeiter in quarantäne zu
schicken wieder rauszuholen wolltest
doch negativ also in einem völligen
chaos existieren muss um mich da auf
weiter flur oft ziemlich alleingelassen
fühlen und durch die steuerprogression
kommt man ja mittelstand auch gar nicht
an so einem punkt wie jetzt große
unternehmen die sicherlich von solchen
maßnahmen wieder profitieren können dass
man wirklich auch mal vermögen schaffen
kann für mich ist es zum beispiel in
bayern nicht möglich aus meiner hart
erarbeiteten kraft also als
einzelunternehmer am ende des tages mir
ein eigenheim einfach so zu leisten also
es ist stellenweise sehr demotivierend
woher soll man jetzt auch jungen
start-up-unternehmen zum beispiel noch
sagen hey seid euch im standort
deutschland an weil das lohnt sich hier
also da gibt es mittlerweile einfach
attraktivere standorte und ich finde das
ziemlich gefährlich für unsere zukunft
sagen tut tut die ampel genug um
unternehmerinnen und uns an ja wirklich
auch zu fördern und zu stützen sie
sprachen gerade einmal das thema eeg
umlage an abschaffung da muss ich
ehrlich gesagt selbst lachen denn wir
wissen glaube ich hier alle am tisch
wenn der stromkunde sie nicht mehr zahlt
dann zahlt der steuerzahler die eeg
umlage muss ja irgendwie finanziert wenn
das heißt frau rehbein zeit
möglicherweise höhere steuern oder das
geld was für steuersenkungen da wäre
kann nicht in steuersenkungen gehen die
eeg-umlage ist die ökostrom umlage ich
erkläre es einfach noch mal ganz kurz
genau und die ampel hat gesagt sie will
sie streichen hat sich schon leicht
gesenkt zu jahresbeginn will sie
generell abschaffen das heißt der
strompreis wird sinken aber das geld das
bekommen die strom hersteller ja
trotzdem das kommt dann dosen mehr von
den stromkunden sondern eben von den
steuerzahlern das heißt dass rechte
tasche linke tasche und das ist glaube
ich blöd wenn man das so als trick
verkauft und als große entlastung das
ist natürlich für viele leute in der
entlastung also beispielsweise für
geringverdiener für rentner für schüler
und studenten der mitte unternehmen
unter absoluter kurve nicht die steuern
aber den
habe ich bei keine lust mehr zwei
sondern gehe ich lieber woanders sehen
denn es kann nicht sein dass wir
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigen bei den
ganzen strafraum wie steam man dafür tut
muss relativ politiker sagt erhöhen ja
nicht die steuern höher
wir haben jetzt ja die partei habe einer
der beiden steuern erhöhen die fdp hat
in der regierung durchgesetzt dass es
keine steuererhöhungen gibt keine neuen
steuern keine erhöhung bestehender
steuern keine vermögenssteuer was auch
gerade für unternehmer wichtig ist keine
erhöhung der einkommenssteuer was für
personengesellschaften wichtiges wir
reden ja nicht nur vom großkonzern
sollen viele mittelständler zahlen ja
einfach die einkommensteuer das heißt
wir haben wir haben keine mehrbelastung
wir schaffen an vielen stellen zum
beispiel ich habe es gerade dargelegt
super abschreibungsmöglichkeiten anreize
um zu ihnen aber er ist ein verschieben
war die sache ist wenn ich mir also ein
absoluter verschiedener macht die ampel
versteht kommt na gut die ampel ist seit
zwei monaten im amt da muss man auch mal
sagen also heißt wir können nicht diese
ganze liste die ganze wunschliste die
verhandler referiert hat na da haben wir
jetzt fehle dafür zeit das zu machen
mich so schnell wie möglich das ganze
und was ich denke was sich ändern muss
es sind in klima im land was gründung
fördert viele jugendliche im land die
möchten lieber job im öffentlichen
dienst kann ich verstehen erst mal
sicher kommt das geld pünktlich und so
weiter wir müssen das eben fördern über
schülerfirmen über die möglichkeit
einfach zu gründen auch immer von einem
tag eine firma zu gründen ich habe
selber drei firmen gegründet also ich
kann
polzin und weiß wie schwierig das ist
eben erst mal alles beieinander hat von
steuernummer bis umsatzsteuer adidas mit
der bank geklagt hatten der gründung und
beim notar und so weiter da müssen wir
wesentlich besser und schneller werden
und eben jugendliche motivieren dass es
sich lohnt in deutschland zu gründen
dazu gehört aber auch hausaufgaben
machen es gibt überall internet jeder
ein mobilfunknetz ja ja und überall
hinkommen tut man auch eine bessere
mobilität also da muss ich ein stück
weit wirklich zustimmten großes problem
ist wir haben seit geraumer zeit einen
ausbildungsplatz zu bieten wir finden
aber keinen geeigneten auszubildenden
tatsächlich weil entweder man noch nicht
mal als pünktlich zum termin kommt der
deutschen sprache nicht mächtig ist mit
zerrissenen jeans ankommt mich dann
als chefin dann sagt das machen was
machst du eigentlich hier
was machst du angeblich sind na ja also
ich wäre rein theoretisch eine chefin
aber jetzt halt auch noch mehr also dass
also die realität in deutschland sieht
ganz anders aus als das politisch immer
so nennt klingen stern viele strenge
chefin überhaupt noch haben sie jetzt
die chance einmal hier werbung zu machen
ja also wir haben einen ausbildungsplatz
zur medizinischen fachangestellten zu
bieten und suchen qualifizierte
hochmotivierte menschen und junge
menschen die eine freude haben in diesem
land mit anzupacken und in einer tollen
arztpraxis zu arbeiten ja ok chefin auch
lieber spricht sich es nicht streng
sondern sie ist sehr engagiert und
wie man ich bin ja ich bin ja voll bei
ihnen ich vermute mal wenn sie meine
wunschliste aufschreiben zehn punkte die
politik machen sollte würden wir neuen
halb davon sagen finde ich als fdp gut
können wir umsetzen wir sind aber jetzt
mal in der regierung mit verschiedenen
parteien und wir kommen auch aus einer
bestimmten situation die letzten 16
jahre merkel nist viele sachen liegen
geblieben die wir jetzt gerade an
hausaufgaben abzuräumen haben sind sie
ein bisschen gnädig mit uns lassen sie
uns mal zumindest ein paar monate zeit
das ganze anzufangen schwierig beim ist
auch keiner gnädig wenn ich nicht
irgendeine steuervorauszahlung abgeben
da muss ich schon muss ich schon
strafzinsen darauf sei und zwar ab der
ersten stunde wurst zu spät kommt mit
uns bürgern ist ja auch keiner gnädig
für als ob ich so dass er alle anrufen
hast du dann kann ich hab ein problem
dieser also im januar beisammen wir tun
ja schon einiges bitte um verständnis
dass wir nicht alles bis gar nicht ihre
schuld dass sind sehr probleme die über
viele jahrzehnte schon ist aber der
eindruck den sie oder das was sie
schildern und der eindruck der sich
glaube ich ergibt bei vielen auch bei
journalisten die das politische
geschehen betrachten ist doch dass das
geld immer er verteilt wird beim thema
wohnkosten zu ist es genauso jetzt gibt
szenen für ungefähr 15 millionen bürger
das mag auch jedem gegönnt sein aber man
tut so nach dem motto also wenn dieses
geld vom himmel fallen würde und das ist
natürlich nicht vom himmel wir haben
leute ihr ganzes leben arbeiten die
nachher meiner rente rauskommen
unterharz hier also wir haben einfach
ein super schlechtes lohnniveau und also
vier jahre funktioniert auch im sonst
allerdings wir haben ein super schlecht
das lohnniveau und ich habe in meinem
wahlkreis verdienen 35 prozent der
menschen also deutlich und haben
mindestlohn er unter zehn euro also
durch den aktuellen mindestlohn und ist
es so dass bei mir knapp 50 prozent der
bevölkerung im wahlkreis unter 1500 euro
netto mitnehmen nach hause und nochmals
40 prozent davon unter 1200 euro
finanzieren sie davon und ich malen klo
ich würde gerne etliche arbeitsplätze
schaffen ich würde gern ich hätte auch
kapazität noch mehr menschen altern wird
durch die wahnsinnig geehrt und ich kann
es mir als unternehmerin gar nicht
leisten weil sie lebenden
lohnnebenkosten sind so hoch wenn ich
mein mitarbeiter ich habe wirklich
zweiter die sind exzellent und den würde
ich so gerne eine enorme lohnerhöhung
geben das kostet mich aber zunehmen so
fehlt dass die 50 euro mehr auf dem
konto haben das ist doch auch schon
absurd aber als angehöriger sozusagen
der mittelschicht würde ich mal sagen
gefühle ich mich von der politik
vergessen denn mit milan schauen auf den
mindestlohn jetzt wird die minijob
zuverdienstgrenze erhöht das kann man
auch alles machen ist vielleicht auch
alles richtig nur was ist denn jetzt zum
beispiel mit mir so als angehörige der
mittelschicht sonst wären sie ja ganz
okay aber die hälfte davon weg
gleichzeitig die förderung beantragt das
einmal doch mal sagen darf ich habe auch
das nicht mal ganz kurz halt immer
wieder heißt kostenlos im kindergarten
das stimmt nicht hält dass man sie nicht
kostenlos
es gibt nichts kostenlos verschieben nur
gebühren wir verschieben und
möglicherweise zahlen die bayern herr
hagen und frau rehbein zahlen dafür dass
mark ehren wert sein zahlen dafür dass
in mecklenburg vorpommern kinder
gebührenfreien kindergarten können es
gibt in diesem land nichts kosten seinem
er immer zahlt irgendjemand da natürlich
zahlt und am ende sind wir am tisch
unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer was
ganz toll ist aber das müssen wir es
glaube ich immer und jeder politiker
muss sie das vergegenwärtigen
nichts ist umsonst und wenn der
politiker wie hinschauen sagt das haben
wir wieder gemacht wie gerne schröder
wir haben eine firma gerettet holzmann
dann hatte ich eher die firma gerettet
dann haben die deutschen steuerzahler
die firma gerettet denen gehört er dann
aber ehrgeiz ist er konkret gefragt was
ist für ihn drin also sparer
pauschbetrag wird profitieren sie direkt
von ausbildungsfreibetrag bedeutet wenn
sie kindern profitieren sie von eg
umlage profitieren so von die
rentenbeiträge sind künftig von der
steuer voll abzugsfähig profitieren so
von also jetzt mal vier punkte wo sie
konkret als angehöriger der
mittelschicht von profitieren ich hätte
auch gern mehr denn auch gerne mehr aber
es stimmt nicht es stimmt nicht dass für
die mittelschicht nichts getan wird aber
auch mehr als jung mit mir werden sie
auf die vermögenspreise also
insbesondere die immobilienpreise ein
riesenproblem ich habe nicht das gefühl
dass die politik des in den griff
bekommt das heißt da werden menschen
wird einer ganzen generation eigentlich
eine lebenschance genommen die noch für
meine eltern generation eigentlich
relativ selbstverständlich da aber dass
man natürlich irgendwie ins eigenheim
kann oder zumindest die chance darauf
hat viele haben mich jetzt nicht mal
mehr theoretisch die chance das
irgendwie zu finanzieren und irgendwie
abzuziehen und wenn es erst darfst du
noch erbschaftssteuer zahlen auf das
bereits schon versteuerte vermögen
seiner eltern also reden wir über den
kern des problems und das ist unser
völlig absurdes verworrenes
steuersysteme und wir sind mittendrin in
der frage macht die ampel gute politik
oder nicht und das ist auch die
überleitung zu johannes arlt dem
spd-bundestagsabgeordneten und ihrem
thema heute abend ja also ich hab mich
diese woche sehr geärgert über die
medien berichterstattung zum thema
ukraine es ist einfach so dass wir als
ja als unsicherer kantonist angestellt
werden das ärgert mich weil wir sind der
zweitgrößte geber weltweiten die ukraine
wir haben seit 2014 1,8 milliarden euro
und dieses land investiert wir haben
auch militärisch mit einem feldlazarett
nach stützt aber ich glaube einfach dass
das vielfach daran liegt dass wir
schneller kommunizieren könnten klarer
kommunizieren können wenn wir eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie hätten
wenn wir wüssten was wir wirklich wollen
wo wir stehen um einem solchen
sicherheitspolitischen krisen wirklich
schneller und currenta auch agieren zu
können dazu gehören noch einsatzbereite
streitkräfte die unser land verteidigen
können so bürger verteidigen können
damit man auch diese fielen steuer euros
die in die streitkräfte investieren die
bürger auch etwas zurückbekommen nämlich
eine echte leistung die mehr sicherheit
bringt ganz im sinne auch eines beitrags
der friedenspolitik im 21 jahrhundert
habe ich sie dabei richtig verstanden
herald das ist jetzt ja doch etwas
weiter gehend dass sie werbung machen
dafür dass die bundeswehr auch bei
beispielsweise einem russischen
zusätzlichen einmarsch in der ukraine
dann auch parat stehen soll und dort
eingreift eingreifen sollten wir sind an
einer nato solche dinge entscheiden war
nicht alleine da gibt es in artikel 5
und die ukraine ist kein nato-mitglied
ja und ich trete ja auch nicht dafür
einen wir haben in deutschland tradition
dass wir sagen wir wir setzen auf die
macht des wortes die setzen auf
diplomatie und das wird ja oft ganz ganz
verschiedenen kanälen gemacht dass wir
dort sprechen und jeder tag an dem wir
sprechen gibt es keine bewaffnete
auseinandersetzungen schon mal ein guter
tag aber ist nicht weil sie das jetzt
gerade sagten und mich hat der auftritt
von olaf scholz in washington doch
durchaus ehrlich gesagt
empört dass ein deutscher bundeskanzler
nicht in der lage ist das wort nord
stream zwei als möglichen sanktionen
skoda einmal in den mund zu nehmen oder
stolz hat es geschafft die wenigen
stunden die an washington war knapp 24
aber das wort nord stream zwei nicht ein
einziges mal
auszusprechen und ich glaube das ist
auch das was sie sagten die hilfen die
wir der ukraine geleistet haben sie
haben ein militärisch überhaupt nichts
haben mit militär in überhaupt nichts zu
tun das ist hilfe beispielsweise in der
energiepolitik hilfe für gutes regieren
wenn man sich anschaut im vergangenen
jahr ging aus deutschland waffen im wert
von fast zehn milliarden in die welt
hinaus unterarm nach ägypten in diesem
militärdiktatur nach ukraine gegen kein
einziges keine einzige waffe kein
einziger euro dann fragt man sich doch
wo ist da eigentlich die
verhältnismäßigkeit warum sträubt sich
vor allem die spd eigentlich so stark
waffen in die ukraine zu liefern ich
finde das bild was die ampel aber
speziell auch ihre partei abgibt das
sage ich unverblümt die schätze sie aber
ihre partei abgibt das ist beschämend
ich finde das nicht bestimmt ich finde
das gut dass wir keine kriegswaffen in
krisengebiete liefern das ist doch ist
nein wir liefern keine kriegswaffen in
krisengebieten rüstungsexport ja ägypten
darüber kann man streiten und wir als
appell haben uns vorgenommen das zu
ändern diese regeln zu überarbeiten dass
auch strenger zu machen da muss man auch
darüber reden wie diese industrie die 45
hatten viele hunderttausend
arbeitsplätze in deutschland auch
bereitstellt gut bezahlte arbeitsplätze
wie die in zukunft natürlich auch
überleben können und welche
möglichkeiten die haben auch für ihre
produkte ab das wenn ich keine waffen
aber nur kurz machen darf keine waffen
in krisengebiete liefern warum liefere
ich dann eigentlich waffen warum brauche
ich eine armee also ich verstehe das
bisher so dass sich demokratien mit
ihren waffen mit ihren armeen wehren
können wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
beliefern eine demokratie die von einem
aggressor bedroht wird und die russland
ist ein aggressor putin ist ein
aggressor bedroht wird dann sagen wir
lieber aggressoren du darfst dazu
schlagen weil wir in so ein krisengebiet
um eine demokratie wie die ukraine zu
schützen keine waffen liefern und dort
nicht helfen diese logik die ist doch
die ist doch bekloppt und es hat auch
mal so zu sagen würde ich so nicht sehen
am meer hat immer ein
abschreckungspotenzial einsatzbereite
streitkräfte abschreibung des schreckens
potenzial was ihm auch hilfe
diplomatischen bühne entsprechend seine
forderungen weiter voranzutreiben also
einsatzbereite streitkräfte die gut
ausgerüstet sind die ein hohes
fähigkeitsspektrum haben die helfen eben
gerade bewaffnete konflikte zu vermeiden
und darum hat man sie ja auch aber das
ist genau der punkt warum helfen wir den
jetzt nicht der ukraine ein
abschreckungspotenzial aufzubauen um
sozusagen militärische kosten für
russland zu erhöhen damit genau das dazu
beiträgt dass russland zurück schreckt
davor hier irgendwie zu
diesem diesen krieg und genau das tun
wir im rahmen der nato wir haben noch
2014 nach der krim krise überall die
niveaus aufgestellt als wir haben
überall multinationale kommandos in den
kleinen ländern am rand der nato
aufgestellt um zu sagen hier sind 27
nationen die haben ja ein paar soldaten
greifst du jemand angreift du uns alle
an wir schicken jetzt hier verdoppeln
jetzt unser beitrag in litauen
dementsprechend an soldaten und leisten
dafür in hahns for web präsenz und für
den schutz der aussengrenzen unseren
beitrag die ukraine ist kein
nato-mitglied wir tun auf diplomatischer
ebene alles um der ukraine zu helfen
also ich meine partei ist ja auch teil
der ampel ich sehe in dem punkt
tatsächlich anders ich glaube wir
sollten die ukraine auch mit waffen
unterstützen mich überzeugt dass nicht
zu sagen in dem moment wo eine
feindliche armee an seiner grenze steht
bist du ein potenzieller konfliktherd
und dann dürfen wir keine waffen mehr
liefern sollen gerade dann müssen wir
doch so ein land unterstützen und ich
glaube auch tatsächlich dass es ein
beitrag zur friedenssicherung ist die
wehrhafter die ukraine ist ein kleines
land von dem überhaupt keine bedrohung
ausgeht dass einem großen russischen
aggressor gegenüberstehen die wehrhafte
diese ukraine ist dass je höher der
preis für wladimir putin wäre wenn er
sagt wir machen da jetzt einen angriff
auf dieses land desto unwahrscheinlicher
wird dieser angriff desto
wahrscheinlicher bleibt ist beim frieden
und deswegen glaube ich ich finde gut
dass wir die ukraine finanziell
unterstützen ich würde auch gut wie die
außenministerin berbalk momentan der
auftritt aber wir sollten auch
militärgerät dorthin liefern also wir
haben ja militärgerät nicht nur die 5000
helm sondern wir haben militärgerät wir
haben wir einen feldhospital geliefert
eines der modernsten geräte hohen
gefechts wert haben dementsprechend was
mobiles verlegt bar ist wir haben 180
schwer verwundete ukrainische soldaten
unserem bundeswehr krankenhäusern
behandelt bereits was ich nicht
verstehen kann ist das quasi die alten
nva kanonen die jetzt irgendwann ist
dann rumstehen an die ukraine geliefert
werden ist das kein problem aber ist das
würde ich etwas legerer sehen da stimme
ich zu und andere länder denen die jetzt
gehört nicht behindern auch wenn die mal
ursprünglich vor 20 jahren oder 30
jahren von uns kamen aber ansonsten
finde ich sollten wir daran festhalten
waffen in krisengebieten die bringen
nichts dann haben die usa auch sehr
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht aber er
alt wie ich das einfach noch mal fragen
darf sie beschweren sich gerade darüber
dass wir als deutsche in der welt
plötzlich so einen schlechten ruf haben
weil wir offenbar als unsicherer
kantonist gelten und wenn ich mir jetzt
überlege die amerikaner keiner hat lust
mit einem auf eine militärische
auseinandersetzung mit russland ganz
klar wenn du jetzt hören deutschland
schickt 5000 helme und hat ein
militärlazarett gebaut und 180
verwunderte aufgenommen ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass der ein oder andere auch
ihrer amerikanischen kameraden bisschen
schmunzelt und sagt mensch auf der welt
sind unsere ganzen flugzeugträger
unterwegs wir sind in verschiedenen
krisengebieten im einsatz da sterben
soldaten
weil sie die freiheit verteidigen und
ihr erzählt uns was das 480 verwundete
soldaten aufgenommen haben ist ein
bisschen mismatch ist aber auch eine
andere gewichtsklasse amerika als wir
auch sicherheitspolitisch das müssen wir
auch sehen dabei und so einfällt
hospital es ist ein substanzieller
beitrag und trotzdem können wir halt
unserer linie treu bleiben und die haben
wir schon seit der wiedervereinigung
dass wir eben dort keine waffen liefern
um es einmal gemacht bei den page merga
ist auch jetzt keine erfolgsgeschichte
die waffen die räder geliefert haben und
ich bin der meinung da sollte man sich
nicht verzetteln aber es war auch
richtig dass wir die bestmarke gestützt
also wir reden jetzt über die über die
irakischen kurden die sich dort gegen
den as verteidigt haben die dort auch
die jesiden geschützt haben vor der
festlegung durch den erst ich glaube es
war doch vernünftig die militärische
auszurüsten grundsätzlich ist das
grundsätzlich ist natürlich absolut
richtig gewesen die zu unterstützen aber
ob die art der unterstützung die
richtige war darüber konnte man
sicherlich diskutieren worüber haben sie
sorge vor einem krieg dass putin die
ukraine richtig überfällt ich habe unten
noch nicht mal unbedingt zu viel sorge
für die ukraine ich habe auch für unser
eigenes land sorge denn ich sehe das
problem ganz anders das kernproblem ist
auch wie ist unsere bundeswehr überhaupt
aufgestellt also wenn man da glaube ich
mal unsere waffenlager schaut und die
rüstung
materialien sich ansieht wie sie derzeit
da sind dann ist das glaub ich
hochgradig peinlich ich weiß gar nicht
wieviele funktionsfähige kampfjets haben
wir dann überhaupt die inzwischen sogar
daran heute schon recht viele aber diese
haben sie haben sie haben völlig recht
sie haben völlig recht also ich war im
geschwader letzten donnerstag und die
haben zeitlichen klar stadt geht von 80
prozent mit den eurofightern er und sich
das stabile an also das wird besser
jetzt nach 15 jahren immerhin ist
natürlich auch lächerlich ja aber sie
haben völlig recht und viele dinge die
auf der wunschliste der ukraine stehen
die wir gerne hätten haben wir selber
nicht mal ausrechnen auswählen auch mal
ein anderes thema nämlich auch da mit
einbringt kurz mal abgesehen von kriegs
bedrohung die natürlich jetzt irgendwo
im raum steht wenn wir einfach mal
drüber nachdenken wofür brauchen wir die
bundeswehr im land und auch ein router
rüstung für die bundeswehr im land dann
brauchen wir die ganz einfach auch für
solche profane dinge wie einen
generalisierten stromausfall
digitalen anschlag hätten und der strom
ist weg auch da brauchen wir unsere
bundeswehr um unser eigenes land am
laufen zu halten und da sind im moment
überhaupt nicht in der lage zu also ich
find auch manchmal bevor wir anfangen
bei anderen ländern und sehr groß
gedanken zu machen vielleicht räumen wir
erst mal intern ein bisschen auf und
stellen uns auf denn grundsätzlich ist
es gut wenn man etwas macht aber er
macht man es ganz und richtig oder gar
nicht und helme zu schicken es halt auch
völlig daneben es ist einmalig so
richtig und gar nicht das ist ein
wirklich sehr gutes schlusswort an
diesem heutigen dienstag abend meine
damen und herren vor den bildschirmen
und auch meine damen meine herren hier
im studio ganz herzlichen dank für diese
wirklich lebhafte diskussion es hat
wahnsinnig viel spaß
ich freue mich würde mich sehr freuen
wenn sie morgen abend wieder ein schein
und natürlich es gibt den neuen viertel
nach acht newsletter den sollten sie
sich auf jeden fall holen ganz
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen ich hoffe
es hat ihnen so viel spaß gemacht wie
uns hier im studio haben sie einen
schönen abend bis bald auch wieder sehen
[Musik]